And for toilets people immediately
just because in the ground.
It's very difficult to get
people once they start doing
that to something which
is more appropriate.
And so they they drive bomb cars and
they use holes in the ground for toilets
and carry water up from the creek in
buckets and that once people achieve
that bottom.
Level of servicing then they just sort
of see the need to progress again.
That's exactly what happens a circle of
poverty and the lack of servicing means
that all people time
and effort is used up keeping
inefficient services going rather than.
Possibly collectivizing and
making more efficiency.
And it can be a actively destructive.
The lack of organization of services for
example as one part in the property where
there are six water pipes all tied
together in a big bundle all running to
different places because no one trusts
to share a pipe with anyone else with
good reason. Historically.
Because the quickest
and easiest way of getting getting back at
your neighbour for any reason is to cut
their water off. And that courses
and reaction in somebody has had their
water cut off which is fire lines.
So that was in the sense
that yes i decided there's no way
that we're going to do any a fish
and implementation of soft
serve. I think technology. Via.
Communities. The didn't seem to be the
degree of trust or resolve or capital
and as well as
that there wasn't the quality of the gear
there either had to build it yourself
and it always looked back yard
and people never trusted it whereas you
had to pay for commercial stuff which is
vastly overpriced.
So we decided
that the real bottleneck in the implementation
of soft earth friendly technology
was the commercial sector. So we decided
well if you can't beat them join them.
And we set up a company to both
resell at reasonable prices.
And also to manufacture. What i'd
call technological missing links.
Key things which you need to make a
system operate and which you can't buy.
And also to get purchasing power because
it's a very strange world out there in the
market. We think that a free market and
anyone's money is as good as anyone else
but it doesn't work like that.
Refusal to deal as almost
the rule not the exception
when you come to to buying technological
things and with the title
and respectable incorporation of
right about power company we found
that we had a lot more
credibility and buying power.
Because suddenly by a lot
cheaper. And if you get.
Get people to sell us things
and give us information
that as individual operators was
impossible. Because us as backyard.
Hippy inventors you've got absolutely
no status in this community.
Once you've got a business card people
treat you like you're on the same planet.
And that was the main
reason that we did it.
And it worked amazingly well it's like these
two societies an invisible one within
the big one an invisible one within the
big one as the people with business clout
with money was respectability who are
financially operating as against the dropouts
inverted commas people who
are considered as nobody's.
Because they haven't got enough
money or political power.
To rejoin get over them.
The progressive if you invented something.
Basic it was with retailing
retailing kicked it all off.
There'd been a few people running market
stalls. Someone from this co-op and and.
Peter from webster's creek and he
wasn't actually living there then.
But there were people staying during
stalls selling things like efficient light
bulbs torches. Bits of
appropriate technology at that.
The markets particularly the china
market which is an amazing.
Focus of entrepreneurship and.
Appropriate technology was one of
the things that went along with
that market format. And that's
what started the idea of buying
and selling as a business. And peter had
been doing that and david been doing that.
And caroline he registered a business sun
source which was doing the same thing she
was buying and selling solar
panels and this buying
and selling as a way of generating money
and getting contacts had an obvious.
Escalation which was to set up a
company and that's what happened.
In.
Yeah.
The second year i think i actually built
the first water well which worked.
Didn't work very well because it's cheap
is to keep wearing out drive belts.
That actually produced a useful
amount of electricity that it.
Actually sat in the creek and used to
get wet the drive belt used to slip.
And the thing used to wear out. And also
i had big political problems with it.
Because. There was a an anti-technology
feeling here a luddite mentality. And.
I was also. I tried to go through
the correct processes of getting.
Co-operative endorsement
of these energy project.
But while i while i actually got that
endorsement for most of the things i did.
I actually raised a flag
and attracted attention from luddite
minorities actually stoned broke interfered
with and destroyed a lot of the
early projects which i put together
and they saw it as an interference
with the spirits of the creek. So.
I'd lot of trouble for
the first few years.
Eventually i i learnt my lesson
and stopped going through the correct
political processes because they.
They got in the way and they drew fire.
It's as if greenies have got this
mindset once something becomes.
Media worthy then it's protest worthy
and whether it's in the newspaper an issue
or whether it's in the local co-operative
tribal meetings an issue is still draws
fire and you get a protest movement
mobilizing for its own sake
and most of the people involved in these
things have got minimal understanding they
tend to be very stupid reactive
people and so i was up against
that the most silly extreme group of greenies
do it as as a way of self-empowerment.
And basically just against everything
on principle and then they turn around
and act as total hypocrites
when they've got to use some of the
mainstream technology for their own comfort.
Anyway.
I won't bitch about the extreme greenies
in the early days of this co-operative it
was it was very irrational
and very emotional.
And my first big technology success
actually did without telling anyone.
With my own money and my own initiative.
I just went and bought a
great pole steel cable.
Strung it up the cliff put an electric
motor on the top and created the first.
Powered transport system in the whole
place which is still working to this date
which i think is 18 years later i think
that that's an amazing achievement and
that means
that i can live a long list my neighboring
four houses without any road access.
We just have a steel cable
going up a 200 foot cliff.
It's been a very appropriate piece
of technology that still cable.
I moved early into electricity
systems because i was both ideology
that we didn't want to connect
to mine more up and it was so.
Legalities we didn't want to tract yet
another government authority to us.
And we want to prove that
alternatives were possible.
So i built two more water wells
before one of actually worked
and it actually ran for five years before
it got devastated an enormous flood.
The will itself didn't get broken
but the dam across the creek did.
So there was limited success
with water powered machines at
that stage little bit later i put
up a recycled wind when mill
and that's still working.
So there's a bit of sporadic one
off successes with energy projects
but i could see
that my life was going to end before
many more one offs were completed.
So i thought that getting
commercial and getting big
and getting mass production was the
only way to have any real major impact.
Of water world and. The
great lakes and. Yes.
What's the same thing. So.
We basically just did in a nicer more
commercial way what we'd already proved
worked. Trying to get.
It and went on. A commercial. Yes.
And sold.
Oh we did some interesting experiment
asian with different sorts of generators.
And we actually did that
fundamental research
that was necessary to make these things
work better than the competition.
And we stood we started with no money
and with no preconceptions as a result
got to a different type of design which
works better in smaller sizes
than anything on the market.
Tells me how.
I don't magic
or idea of living it closer to
nature without interfering with it.
I'd read african genesis by adria
like the i developing in forests.
I hated lawnmower style. The thing i
detested most about the suburban nightmare.
So i pledged i would build a house
somewhere where i did not have to have a
lawnmower.
So i actually picked a piece of totally
standard ordinary eucalypt forest.
Which had reasonable access.
Once i put this cable up.
I didn't have to fight any territorial
wars with anyone else who wanted
that the land or the water or the
the access or something like that.
So it's a totally ordinary anonymous site
in the middle of an australian mountain
range. And i built a house there. The
house was defined for a much by the site.
It had to be fireproof had to be proof
against falling timber. It had to be cheap.
It had to be maintenance free.
And when i didn't have to protect that
nasty chemicals or the chainsaw so.
The only one that fitted that
the bill perfectly was a dome.
I'd always been interested in domes because
of the structural elegance of these
very little materials
in a very high strength
and one way in which we can use less of
the earth's resources the city is more
efficient structures like
my house ways 10 tons.
That might sound a lot
but your average brick veneer house with a
fraction of the strength weighs about 10
times that amount. So. Foreign
mental impact was there.
It was measurable.
The thing was made of cement
and steel both have got a
definite environmental impact.
It's not particularly bad if you
look at the life cycle impact of
that technology and a
small amount of it used.
So it was basically just a
demonstration way of living.
Soft impact housing. You
know i ignored them.
I've learnt my lesson but then don't
make waves you don't draw fire.
So i went through all the right
moves with a cooperative.
I even put in a picture of it
to the building inspector.
Just the minimum application.
I got the message back he didn't believe
in domes and that was the end of it.
No further correspondence entered into
until seven years later they suddenly
discovered that i was loved to become legal
by dint of being an existing structure.
So the limits of location were
about to fall on my side.
But then we put in some more planes
and got the thing legitimized.
And i was able to actually
thanks to paul lander.
Passed not ordinance 70
but structural engineering testing which
of course my house fail passed easily in
fact i became part of the test weight.
I stood on top of the ton of weight on the
weakest place. So that was a lot of fun.
It was nice feeling that
slight amount of bureaucratic.
Acceptability.
Oh there was never an issue
that the dome was too weak.
That would irritated me so much about
didn't 70 it was not about strength.
It was not about appropriateness.
It was not even about
health was about code.
And the fact
that you've got the option to either
get your structure passed by code
or by engineering tests.
I think is the way the world should be.
Anything. Personal life was disastrous.
I was terribly lonely not living.
I was living in one of
the hamlets in the place
and we worked pretty much as a
group and that together and so on.
I became quite quite mad from sleeping
alone for too many years and.
There's an enormous shortage of women.
And the ones that were tended
to be attracted by people.
With more services of course not.
That lived on top of the cliff.
So that wasn't so much. The trouble.
It was really the conflict
between homesteaders
and free love hippies
and we had this both ideals side by
side literally where you get one lot of
neighbours who would be very morally
vindictive about people are sleeping around
and then you'd have next door people who
didn't believe in marriage in the least.
And if you try to possessive
that was a heavy trip man
and i believe reality is sort of
somewhere in between the two extremes.
And i think that's where i always was.
But i had a reputation as a terrible
philanderer which wasn't totally deserved.
And.
I didn't make it as one of the breeders.
In the period when you told. Yes.
I felt a lot of reverse
sexism in this community.
I i don't know whether
i was totally right.
But i certainly perceived that men were
considered as extremely expendable
and freshen a very mercenary way
simply as house builders. You see.
The role of a man in that utopian
community was extremely ill defined.
In many of the cases the women
usurped the natural roles of men.
I'm not complaining about that.
I think it's appropriate that they
did but the women wore overalls.
They were extremely aggressive they were
territorial they were very much interested
in their own pecking order.
They weren't very interested in the men's
little games men became very much.
Also rounders and their own use as
whether they could produce food or.
Build houses they weren't of any financial
use because women could get much more
money for mother growing
dope or social security
or even prostitution in a few cases so
many of no use would ever financially.
And once they built the house.
So usually disposed of as well
and there's a shortage of women there are
a bit more menace as always been the case
in the australian outback
and a lot of the women were coming from
a situation of persecution in fact.
I think it's a fair generalization
that many of women who ended up
here were coming here to escape.
Sexist oppression by men
and men came here for idealistic
dreams of freedom and
and utopia. Women tend to
come here to escape men and.
I think had a miserable time because
back in suburbia. They got basically.
Used financially by being under
the thumb of men particularly
when they had young kids.
They came here to get away from men and
suddenly they could have their freedom.
But then they found the tyranny
that they didn't have well
enough service situation so
that they missed their cars they
missed their houses and particularly
when you got young kids. I think
you need servicing more than ever.
You were doing in your life.
Suddenly all of the the middle
class values of flushed to.
Well it's in cars and
security and things like
that become very important
because you've got little kids.
And that that makes it a necessity.
So anyway what i was getting to i guess is
that men were seen very much as mercenary.
Contracts and the game was.
You build houses and fix cars and
you get to go to bed with me.
And that was the way the
social contract worked
and of course i'd always been a romantic
ideals to i believe in soulmates i
believed in equality of the sexes i believed
in all the sort of lovely flower child
sort of stuff and.
I was extremely hurt to be taken as
purely a provider of the building
so i did a bit of building houses and
a bit of fixing people's water pipes
and a lot of wiring people's houses
and all sort of thing but it seemed
that sex in return for labor
was it was unsatisfying
emotionally.
So not. With are not generally
deeper emotional level.
And that wasn't my side i kept falling in
love with women was a terrible problem.
And of course men are a nuisance
particularly if there are love with you. So.
And when you try
and make demands because your happiness
is totally dependent upon getting in
someone else's bed which i think so.
Farcical situation but that's the situation
in which most men found themselves.
So. Just like that.
Get falling in love with people kept.
Sleeping alone kept feeling depressed.
Was a cycle that went over and over
again. That the decision that.
Did you make a decision. You
know and yes very strongly.
That seemed like a bad joke.
Wendy wendy to me i was after about
15 years but less than that actually
but 12 years of this. As long
have to try out all of the.
Life options.
And to find a life option i
was wanted children and.
When i discovered that i sterile anyway
that was sort of like the last bad joke.
So it seemed like.
A way of disposing of
that whole problem area of my life.
I think got dosed up and
i'm female hormones
that work unbelievably well
i recommend it for many.
Depressive suicidal lovesick males.
It's worked its works for you and
you. Solve that problem. Totally.
Yes. It was a problem for other people to.
Quite frankly i did i thought that was their
problem. I didn't know them anything.
I thought it was their
problem to deal with
and it was not really a problem anyway i
thought well things quite quite funny.
How did the people to his actions.
Oh i get treated as mad
but then most people are treated as a
man who live here anyway so what does
that mean. It did.
Further worsen the credibility problem.
I felt that i always had communication
problems because i was all.
It's being shouted down by a loud mouth
people who repeated themselves 10 times
and got they way
that was sort of like a syndrome which had
been going ever since the beginning of
the co-operative i couldn't
believe my media dropping status
when i came to live untouchable
compared with being a schoolteacher.
I wasn't particularly
authoritative as a schoolteacher
but i got christmas at least
anyone's equal was coming here.
I was immediately suspect because i was
from the straight science community which
is considered as a as a demonic religion.
And i didn't ever doubt my principles of
what i call straight science my ideas of
truth my belief structure i think
is the way they put it now
and never been under much threat
and never and still isn't.
And for that reason i was considered
a little bit spiritually limited.
And very suspect
and certainly not a accorded much
credibility in the community.
So
that got a bit worse with a gender change
because women tend not to have much credibility
either particularly it comes
to cars and things like that
that many years ago perhaps.
You know. It's very male dominated it
tends to involve male egos very heavily
and it's considered as mad
and lacking in credibility anyway because
people almost worship mains power.
Mains water the utility authority is
very close to the the image of male
authority in our in our culture.
And anyone who doesn't believe in
those things has got to be a maniac.
I mean peter pedal suffered a lot of this.
He was considered
impractical people sort of.
People actually accept him quite well
because he's so obviously eccentric
that it's not a threat that
he disagrees with them.
So in that way he was much more
successful at putting his message across
that me he was a bit more of a sort of a.
A denying revolutionist or
saying this is morally wrong
and stupid the way things are done with
he wouldn't be nearly so confront tatian
was that the goods there except peter
pedals having silly ideas like
that one should. Good pedal to raise
power to run a television set.
People can laugh at it.
People can treat him as a joke and for
that reason is not as confronting i was
much less tactful i think than peter
and people didn't want to hear what i
had to tell them so i always had this
credibility problem. To
have you become more.
I've learned about a few things i've become
very cynical about women's motivation
in love affairs but then i also
don't hold it against them.
I think that it just means a very different
thing to a woman and man to be in love.
And. I think. The naive idea that there's
no difference between the sexes.
That was around in the sixties and
seventies the same proved wrong.
Is an enormous difference between
the sexes in lots of things.
Most. Well and i know
women are coming from.
And also know a lot more about what women
are coming from too because i have become
one in many ways.
And. Always.
Reclusive but yes i changed sexual
partners as well as gender.
I noticed most people don't know.
In the history of tangible.
It was an amazing social experiment.
And it's still going on.
And.
I think money is the key thing which now
turns out to be central to the whole issue.
Incredible damage was done to
our coalition as a community.
By money as in drug money
and in social security money was paid in
the way which it could be most destructive
to community spirit.
I'm a little bit vicious about the
department of social insecurity on
that one the way in which they handed out
the money was almost obviously designed
to destroy any community based movement.
It was given to individuals
on behalf of their kids.
It was given to.
Women were paid to leave men as one of
the effect of the way it's structured.
You were paid to scam you
were only paid if you lied
and you got.
Continually kept in a state
of paranoia by random
and unreasonable cut offs with a lack
of any long range contracting about the
payment of social security so that
people didn't use it efficiently
and couldn't use it efficiently
and it maintained a sort of a live from
day to day my lifestyle which is absolute
death in any planned community because
nearly everything which is productive has
got to be kept going over a long
period. So money was very destructive.
The effect of the drug itself was destructive
lots of people became alcoholics
and heavy dope smokers and i think that
there are lots of psychiatric overtones
that heavy use of marijuana which are not
being fully admitted i think at the very
least it encourages different psychosis.
Paranoia forgetfulness and laziness
are obvious but i think there's a.
Keep a things and that too. I think
this is the type of schizophrenia
that people get
and they've been smoking a long time.
Children as the other enormous factor.
We can't underestimate
how much children here.
Partly because are living in such a close
situation extended family had enormous
power outside society especially constructed
to protect people from children the
put in schools that they're
bombarded with media and they're.
The rules
and authorities about how they're meant
to be treated here there are no rules
and justice in the politics the people are
the loudest voices tend to get the most
safe children because they make a lot of
noise tend to totally dominate there was
the tail wagging the dog many family groups
were totally dominated by the needs of
the children. And. I think to the children's
own destruction in send several cases.
So the children get brought up totally
spoilt self-indulgent by the time
that they're 10 the smoking
dope by the time they're 12
that they peddling heroin on the street
and that's the way a lot of our
children have gone. It's just too easy.
No emphasis on constructive
behavior. You know.
You know. You know. I've no idea.
Like i consider myself a genuine
smaller liberal but also a moralist in
that i think you haven't got a right to
take what you can get you've got to an
obligation to community at
least as much as yourself.
And i see lots of people
that are totally selfish.
And you know this got to be a balance
between the rights of the individual in the
community as it is a very obvious
state. There's also fundamental.
What about the challenges of
managing and. That. In a minute now.
You know. Things change and.
Yes. Gradually the conventional
services are becoming more expensive.
They're not being subsidized as much by
government and they're not being made.
So much in the way of compulsory can
consumption because so much of western culture
i see as compulsory can consumption.
People don't even know how much they are
consuming after time like they're starting
to at least measure water rates in in lismore
and you pay more if years more water.
I mean
that radical idea is only just now appeared
in lismore there's a funny attitude
towards services as rights that you have
being a. White anglo-saxon protestant.
With.
I consider the right to consume the world's
resources is only a very modest one.
So that feelings coming in.
Also appropriate technology
is getting a lot cheaper
and thanks to people like growing up our
company is getting more available service
to back to all of those
things that consumers want.
Solar panels for example of consistently
been getting better and cheaper so
that now you can actually run a remote
house on solar panels. If you're careful.
I think the biggest success this
particular property has had with energy
and impact is that. It's not so much
to have done anything different.